well Johnny is now is Northern Ireland
secretary Chris Heaton Harris
representing the government this morning
hello thanks for joining us on the
program lots to talk about with Northern
Ireland I know you made a statement uh
yesterday lunchtime after pmqs but first
let's talk about nurses should we
um I'm going to give them any more money
um
well they are getting some more money I
mean that nurses pay has been set set by
independent bodies for quite some time
and uh and that award has been made and
will be and will be paid and
um but I you know it I want to say like
everybody would like to that you know
nurses doctors everybody in the NHS went
that extra mile during the time of the
pandemic actually they were the only
group of people who got a pay Rise
um in the public sector in the pandemic
three percent pay Rise
um and um
but the ask of the RCN the Royal College
of Nursing at 17
um is is a high ask and I believe even
even labor say they can't afford that
nurses get paid enough as it is
um that's very difficult to judge I mean
I I was looking at the pay bands it's
not my area of expertise as you'd
understand I know but yeah yeah no no
exactly right uh and um you know I know
it's a vocation
um I suppose you could say politics is a
vocation in many ways
um and uh a a nurse will start on 27 000
pounds rising to I think it's banned
Five band Six in the in the kind of low
to mid 30 000 pounds is that enough
I mean who put a value on something on
care like that
um uh politicians do nurses deserve as
much pay as politicians
um
well some people wouldn't want to pay
politicians anything so I think nurses
not my question I know but I'm a
politician uh I think that's an unfair
question because we're in completely
different places but nurses are using
food banks they're saying and having to
eat leftover food that patients have not
eaten yeah I've heard those stories too
and they've been and they're troubling
and actually very very sad but
everything the government is doing
across the whole of of public sector pay
which is the only pay sector that we can
influence is is aiming at the the lower
paid and the more more vulnerable in
society as well when we offer more
packages of support
um so we understand that we need to help
people a bit more
um Minister the education secretary was
on yesterday said there's no point in
nurses going on strike because there's
no more money
um do you agree with that
I think well I used to be brown Minister
and I used to engage with the Royal
unions a huge amount and actually I do
think there's uh those discussions are
actually generally valuable because
politicians will
unless we come from the background that
we of the department that uh in rail I
wasn't a real women so I needed to
understand better the asks of the
conditions the industry itself
um so the engagement is definitely worth
a thing but yeah Public public sector
finances are uh not in the best of
shapes and we're trying to stabilize our
economy make sure we drive it forward so
uh you know there are better times ahead
um but 17 ask is a very big ask in
public sector terms so just to clarify
is it a pointless strike because there's
no more money for nurses um
I'd never say strike is pointless but
this completely disrupts a huge host of
Public Services
that are very very important to the
whole nation and dialogue is always the
best way
um
what about nurses in Northern Ireland
who do they negotiate with yeah that's a
really good question because up until
the 28th of October
um that had been a negotiation with the
minister for health uh there currently
there is no Minister
um and so
um I'm afraid some of those
responsibilities now fall to me you keep
kicking the I can down the road what's
the latest situation um
it's a can that everybody else wants to
kick down the road everybody says to me
that elections in Northern Ireland at
this point in time will just polarize
Society a great deal more and actually
come up with no no different results and
so the latest situation is yesterday in
the House of Commons
I was going to
try and get some primary legislation
through the house to delay the elections
to the new year to give time and space
to two very important things for the
North Nine parties to come together for
more discussions about going back into
the assembly so local people can make
local choices on their constituents
behalf but also so the UK government and
the European commission can have some
time and space to talk and negotiate
about the Northern Ireland protocol
which is one of the key reasons why the
unionist community in Northern Ireland
um and their representatives won't go
into the executive
um usefully on Ireland correspondent
David Blevins I was chatting to him last
night and he pointed out that on the 3rd
of October you said you would push the
button and call it a stormbound election
if Devolution had not been restored by
the 28th of October then on the 18th of
October you told the Northern Ireland
Affairs committee you would call an
election a Devolution had not been
restored by the 28th of October then on
the 28th of October you said you were
disappointed that the evolution had not
been restored and would be calling an
election yesterday you said you wouldn't
be calling an election forgive me for
being a politician that listens to
people but I did when when so on the one
minute past midnight on the 28th of
October the responsibility of all
ministers disappeared in Northern
Ireland so and there's a very very big
budget black hole in Northern in
Northern Ireland's finances and all
those responsibilities fell to me I've
been talking to all the political
parties I've been talking to businesses
to community groups to uh ordinary folk
on the streets and no one wanted an
election
um and uh and I've now done something
that creates the time and space for
conversations to take place so the
executive hopefully can reform and for
conversations to take place between as I
say the UK government and the European
commission
um to try and solve one of the biggest
obstacles to that what's the big problem
uh in which way there's always problems
um the big problem is the protocol
and for the unionist community because
it means a whole host of goods are not
available in Northern Ireland that
should be and are available in the rest
of of Great Britain uh and uh that needs
to be solved
how do you do that by negotiations with
showing trust and respect with the
European commission as far as the
European commission is concerned and
indeed the European courts EU law your
boss Richardson said that oh he's
certainly talking tough when he was
chatting to me in the summer as saying
that EU law most of it would be scrap it
would have nothing to do with us by the
end of his tenure by the next election
is that something that you agree with
yeah I mean so it's it's for all you
laws would have been transposed onto our
statute books and the bits that are
remaining the references to uh European
law there's a bill going through the
House of Commons at this very point in
time to remove those so how do you see
the 2023 how do you see this being fixed
you talk about the Northern Ireland
protocol we know that the Northern
Ireland protocol is an incredibly
vexatious subject that no one seems to
be able to fix yeah I mean it has been
like that
um and firstly can I I should say that
when it was written I honestly don't
think the people behind mind writing it
thought it would have the ramifications
of it I thought it was oven ready this
time no no the the the protocol so
politicians are legislators legislators
are are very good at creating law but
when the rubber hits the road sometimes
you get unforeseen consequences so uh
Johnson was wrong to say that it was an
oven ready deal um no it was an oven
ready deal and the European commission
who also who co-authored the protocol
um uh with the UK government
um you know everybody believed that this
would this would work already Minister
how can you not how can Northern Ireland
be completely rudderless um but it's
Northern Ireland's not rudderless in
fact that's that's really quite untrue
what Northern Ireland is is local
devolved government to work which is set
up 25 years ago 25 years ago by the
Belfast Good Friday agreement the
institutions do need to work and when
they are working they really do help
with peace and prosperity
um across Northern Ireland my job is to
try and get them back to work the
biggest is the Northern Ireland protocol
everybody the European commission the UK
government Irish government people in
Northern Ireland everybody realizes that
it's a problem that needs to be solved
it needs to be solved by an honest
understanding and respect and Trust on
both sides we have that and now not
having the elections this in this
calendar year has cleared some space for
the elections be
um so I haven't moved them that far into
the future
um I've given myself two periods of six
weeks
um so three months uh yeah and so uh
that essentially means the first three
months of next year so there will be an
election there will be an election in
the first three months of next year
you sure yeah positive yeah okay
um talk to me um about
Gavin Williamson
um Gavin Williamson's resigned I know he
has what did you think about what he had
to say
um well he did something he allegedly
did something that is very which is a
very serious allegation um a very very
serious allegations
um against him so he was right to resign
was he should he have been given a job
in the first place I mean I was looking
at some reports overnight suggesting
that the Prime Minister knew about these
allegations and still gave him a job
yeah well I'm I haven't heard or seen
any evidence of that and what if it's
true as you will recall I was the
government Chief whip for I know uh for
six months in that language
um I I would never have used language
like that um that's not my style but
maybe that's why I'm not Chief whip
anymore because does the chief whip need
to use that sort of no I think the chief
what but a chief whip does need to be
um be firm and
um uh but you know Gavin Williams
the allegations against him are very
serious and he's resigned and that was
the right thing to do yeah but should he
have been given the job in the first
place um uh he was given a job I don't
know what the what people knew at what
times and um so I'm not going to comment
on speculation like that but what if the
Prime Minister did know was it a lot of
what-ifs isn't it no not really yeah
because the suggestion is that he did
know and he's sort of on the premise is
almost hinted at the fact that he he
knew something was going on but he
needed his support I think that's all
speculation and and the wonderful thing
about um the United Kingdom is that you
are innocent until you're proven guilty
he's resigned from his post
um there's investigations going on and
that's the right and proper thing to
happen what do you think of him as a man
you obviously know him
um I actually don't know quite well
although he did give me my first
um job he was Chief Whip and I was a
whip a very Junior whip in in his office
um and uh you know he he was he was a
half decent boss
even though he allegedly tells people to
Slit their throats and jump out of women
I've never seen that behavior in him
which is why I say you're innocent until
you're proven guilty and let the
investigation take its take its place
okay and as far as Matt Hancock is
concerned yeah well he should be here
with us
um voting and and debating in Parliament
did you watch him on the Telly no I'm
afraid I don't watch it don't tell
anybody do you not watch it well it's
very good actually yeah it is but um he
he did look at a bit of a book yesterday
it has to be said and it does look as
though he's gonna going to get a very
hard time I so I know the format of the
show and um I I do believe there's quite
a lot of people in a building not too
far away from here the House of Commons
and the House of Lords who've downloaded
a certain app so they can vote I'm not
sure if that's a good thing is that
right yeah yeah that's a great story is
that true yeah of course it is wow
that's amazing um so you think that he
should be here you think it's totally
inappropriate that an MP should be the
other side of the world I mean I I've
read this morning what he said about
what Harry wants to prove that all you
know all the MPS are human and that's
actually you know that is true all MPS
are human but
um I think we do that every day and our
constituencies and and what we do in
Parliament okay you've got a call like
me haven't you I wish you better thank
you thanks very much for joining us much
appreciated thank you